hello my name is Rafa Heine I work both
from research as a consultant I work
remotely from Poland
my top would be about library link I
will present a few tips and tricks on
how we can make your code faster more
memory efficient and more elegant
so let me start with a picture here so
you can see the programming world that
we currently living so I assume you all
here use and the Wolfram language so
place it in the center but around us
there are also other popular languages
like C C++ or Java and this is the
better now
okay all right so it so happens that we
can use all those libraries written in
other languages from within the Wolfram
language and to achieve to achieve this
we use something called links so for
example for java we have j link and for
c and c++ we have library link and this
is the topic of this presentation but i
will not provide a detailed overview of
the library link and instead i will just
give you a hugh i was reconnected tips
and tricks about this framework so the
first thing i would like to talk about
there is I also called passing modes so
if you recall the
the usual invocation of library function
node as the first argument here is the
library name then we have a function
name and there comes the argument
specification so this is a list of types
of input arguments and as you know if
you want one of the arguments to be a
tensor we shall provide a list like this
and when the first element is the data
type and here in this case it's integer
but for tensors we can also use real or
complex and second element of the list
is and the tensor rank so this can be
any natural number you can also use an
underscore so this is like a match all
pattern and basically that's it but
there is also a third element which can
be omitted and in which case it's
automatic and this is the passing mode
so it determines how tensor is passed to
the to the library code so the default
one the automatic is means that and what
you get in the C code is a copy of the
original tensor and that copy is
automatically cleaned later so this is
like the safest possible option because
you can't accidentally overwrite the
original data and those who don't have
to manually manage it in memory after a
function returned but as you probably
know this is not the most efficient one
because you need to make a copy of the
tensor so in many cases when you only
intend to use the tensor in a read-only
manner you can specify a constant
passing mode like this and here what you
get in your library function is a
reference to the original tensor
and yes and reference should not be
modified but we also have two other
modes for example if you want to modify
the data so you want a copy of the of
the original tensor but you don't want
it to be automatically cleaned after
functioning terms you can use the manual
mode and then you become responsible for
the memory management and the fourth
option is third one so if you intend to
have a tensor that is passed from the
top level code to the libraries and bag
some modifications may be done and then
the tensor is again passed to the
library then it makes sense to use the
Shred mode so you have this tensor that
is owned by both top level code in the
library and you only passing the
reference to it so in that case library
Inc its it maintains a certain table of
shared objects and it counts the
references and if you are not convinced
if these types are that important if the
specimens are that important then Utley
and demonstrated so what I do here is
that is I have a demo library with demo
one function so this function is not
very sophisticated and basically creates
a new tensor here and it copies some
data to the new tester and it returns it
so here I am loading this demo one
function with three different passing
modes yes with automatic constant and
shared
and let's see how this performs all
right so I'm calling this function with
a tensor of different size and as you
can see the constant and shared mouse
well perform similar similarly and about
twice as fast as the automatic mode and
this makes sense because we create one
test or inside the function but in case
of automatic there is another copy my
test because we need to copy the the
input tensor so and the bottom line here
is that if you don't intend to modify
the test or contents just use a constant
mode or something that does not make a
copy and one thing that I should mention
here is that
yes so the difference is depth in in
case of a shared vector tensor the
library ring contains a certain table of
shared objects so it counts the
references I mean it's aware that you
are dead this very this tensor is shared
between the library and and the top
level code and in case of a constant
tensor you know you only get the
reference but it is not internally
managed in the library link all right so
yes one short warning here basically to
not do what I did in the previous slide
so it turns out that if you want to have
one function and load it with different
passing modes it may not end well
because if you want to write your C code
here or C function and you receive a
tensor and there is basically no way to
determine what passing mode was used in
this case so yeah you know you can't
write a generic code it will do the
cleanup
if the passing mode was for example
manual and skip it otherwise so the
thing is that you should decide
beforehand what about passing mode will
be used with this function and just
stick with it okay so together with with
passing modes we also have returned
modes but in this case we only have two
two different modes yes so the default
is the automatic so basically when your
function returns
the library link takes ownership of the
tensor so you don't have to worry about
freeing the memory and if you want to
have this tensor shared between your
library and and between the top level
code and then you can use it with shred
mode and the ownership is shared between
the librarian and and the top level
course we can prolong the life of this
tensor in your library and so far I've
only been talking about M tensor baths
and those passing and return modes they
also apply to other library data
structures like sparse arrays and images
and also row arrays so now you're
probably wondering what a row array is
and it's okay because this is not
documented well if you're a keen
observer you may have noticed that in
warm library that age in am argument
definition we have this one of the
possible types is M Rho array but you
know if you want to learn something more
about it then go to our a reference page
for library link you will find nothing
but as it turns out a lot of people
actually started using it so here is a
query on Mathematica Stack Exchange with
about 30 results
and so now let me tell you a few words
about a robbery so first of all the most
important thing is a disclaimer that and
the robbery has not been documented yet
and officially released so basically
whatever I tell you today tomorrow may
no longer be true but anyway here is an
example how to create a robbery in top
level code so you pass a list of
elements so these are the contents of
the robbery and there is the underlying
type and in return you get this nice box
with an icon and a short summary here
and to get the data back you have to
normal ice-t
robbery so what's so nice about role is
is that they occupy less memory then
then tensor with the same contents so
for Row array we have 101 bytes in this
case and after unpacking it's 160 bytes
and as you can see in the plot here so
I'm creating robberies and tensors of
increasing size and I'm adding small
integers to these containers so 8-bit
integers and it is expected the
robberies I size it only grows about one
byte for new element and in case of
tensor the size grows much much faster
and the underlying reason for that is
that in robberies we support multiple
types so if you recall for tensors we
only had three different types integer
complex and real and now there are many
more so you know if you intend to only
store small integers in your container
then you can use a row array of integer
eight type and it will occupy less space
and the tensor so when you create your
robbery in in or from language you
should use these names four types and
you can also create the structure in
your library code and in this case these
are the identifiers so as for the
functionality of row erase it's very
similar to 2m tensor functionality yes
so interface is basically the same but
of course with different function names
and okay so the bottom line here is that
we have a new memory efficient container
which is not documented yet so you can
use it at your own risk
but yet but it's very efficient compared
to 2n tensor and the next thing I would
like to talk about about different kind
of performance
mainly about the code quality and
maintainability so here what we have is
a well from language with library link
they are kind of grown together and
suppose you want to link a seed library
so in that case everything is fine
because library link has a C interface
and libraries also see so the code you
need to write you know will fit nicely
here so and that is okay but it often
happens that the library want to link is
written in something more modern in C++
or specialist 1114 and in that case we
need to before we can link this library
whatever think we need to get rid of all
those nice features that C++ provides
like exceptions templates classes etc so
it's not a very pleasant task but what
we are working on right now is to
provide a certain additional layer
around library link called library' link
utilities yeah we changed to provide a
modern interface to the library link
action ality and the process of linking
and this library will be
much more feasible so let me now present
you main points of those utilities so
how does it differ compared to library
link so for example the main thing is
that in library link as it is written in
C there are no namespaces and no classes
of course they are somehow simulated by
adding prefixes to function names but
that's not what we really want
so in those utilities we just wrap the
existing structures into proper classes
and we also make use of the opera
operators that are available in C++ and
another thing is that the resource
management is also automated so in C in
library link and basically the developer
is responsible for allocating the memory
in the allocating but the utilities we
have classes so this is done in
constructors and destructors so you
don't need to be afraid that you forget
to do in the memory so as soon as your
container those out of scope the memory
will be D allocated and the next thing
also quite important is error handling
so as you know try no exceptions in C
and we need to utilize those error codes
so each function may return an error
and it's returned as a result so after
each call we need to check the error
variable and properly handle the error
if it occurs and yes and that's
basically for every function whereas in
C++ and never link utilities you just
write the code that you want to write
and the only thing you need to be
prepared for is to caption an exception
and handled and another thing is called
something called iterators so there is
no thing like that C and in library link
so here is a short code to some of the
elements of a tensor and we're asking
until 2 it is where all the containers
are wrapped into proper classes we may
equip those classes with metals like
begin and end and in that case we'll
make use of some built-in features in
C++ in this case these are range based
for loops and we can also use directly
standard functions like accumulate so we
can get the same result in just one line
[Music]
and this order here well it depends on
on what the was the datatype intensity
no no this just deal yes the 11th time
of course better to use references here
yes I mean only in case of amines it
doesn't make much difference but if you
don't want to copy the the element from
from the container you can use a
reference type but yes in in this case
this is a mint alright so I think
there's one one more feature of library
link utilities and maybe even the most
important one so it turns out that for
in case of library link one of the
problems is that and the type of data is
not known at at compile time so the data
type is stored as one of the fields in
in M tensor structure so to verify if
the input dancers in this case T and s
at the same time you have to do this
this F here and it is evaluated each
time when this function is called so if
there is a type mismatch you need to
handle it at runtime and what's more as
the library link interface uses
different function names for for
different data types you need to write
the same code three times if you want to
handle all possible tensor types so
that's not very convenient and
in terms in in case of library link
utilities where tensor is a proper class
and it's also templated so the template
parameter is the data type which means
that type of the tensor is known at
compile time so we may get some help
from from the compiler to detect all
type mismatches for example if I were to
pass two tensors of different data type
here the code won't won't even compile
mmm well in this wing we can also use
the swap function here okay so one more
thing about the utility so this is still
work-in-progress
it's not released yet but actually we
are planning to release this library on
on our github profile yes so welcome
research has a it have account and it's
possible that quite soon those utilities
will be available on github so we'll be
able to you know fork it add your own
modifications whatever you want but I
don't want to make any promises when
this will happen and as for the other
useful sources of information you can
always recommend reading the the
official library link tutorial and we
also have something more general C C++
interface guide and of course there is
also an active community of people using
library link so we can check Stack
Exchange or our our own Wharram and
community page
okay so that's all I have for today mmm
I think we still have like two more
minutes for questions and also and the
next like 30 minutes I will be
downstairs the image processing book so
you can catch me there mmm okay so are
there any questions right now yes
all right
now unfortunately the iterators right
now are not very intelligent so you know
because the memory is starting one just
out of memory so yes it will just go
linearly
[Music]
yes of course
all right so there are no more questions
then thank you for your attention
[Applause]